welcome to the dynamic world of devops
where Automation and efficiency reign
supreme devops has emerged as a
transformative approach fusing
development and operations to streamline
workflows enhance collaboration and
boost efficiency this Dynamic Fusion has
given rise to a multitude of
groundbreaking projects that are
reshaping the industry so in this
explanation of the top 10 devops
projects will delve into the innovative
solutions and tools that are catalyzing
progress from Automation and
containerization to continuous
integration and deployment these
projects not only facilitate agility but
also Drive excellence in software
delivery ensuring that devops remains at
the Forefront of modern technology so
join us as we embark on a journey
through the most influential devops
initiatives of our time with that said
if these are the types of videos you
would like to watch then hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon to
get notified and if you are a
professional with minimum one year of
experience and an aspiring devops
engineer looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no simply
learns postgraduate program in devops
from ctech University in collaboration
with the IBM should be your right choice
for more details use the link mentioned
in the description box below so let's
start with why are devop skills
crucial understanding devops is vital
for for optimizing the software
development life cycle devops Engineers
need to master several key skills Linux
proficiency many firms prefer Linux for
hosting apps and managing configuration
systems it's essential for devops
engineers to be well wored in Linux as
it's the foundation of tools like chef
anible and puppet continuous integration
and continuous delivery CI ensures teams
collaborate using a single version
control system while CD automates design
testing and release improving efficiency
and reducing errors number three
infrastructure as code automation
scripts provide Swift access to
necessary infrastructure a critical
aspect with containerization and Cloud
Technologies ISC manages configuration
executes commands and swiftly deploys
application infrastructure configuration
management tracking software and
operating system configurations ensures
consistency across servers tools like
anible chef and pet simplify this
process making it efficient at number
five we have automation devops aims for
minimal human intervention maximizing
efficiency familiarity with automation
tools like grel git jenin and Docker is
essential for devops and genius so these
tools streamline development processes
and enhance productivity moving on to
the first project of the day we have
unlocking efficiency of Java application
with gridle meet griddle The Versatile
build automation tool transcending
platforms and languages this project
helps you start on a journey of Java
application creation breaking it into
modular sub projects and more the main
aim of this project is to help you
master project initiation as a Java
application adaptly build it and
generate meticulous test reports you
will be well versed in running Java
applications crafting archives and
elevating your Java development Pros so
dive in to transform your coding skills
with grd the source code for this
project is linked in the description box
below moving on to project number two
unlock robust applications with Docker
for web servers Docker the go-to
container technology revolutionizes
services and app hosting by virtualizing
operating systems and crafting Nimble
containers this project focuses on
creating a universal base image and
helping you collaborate with fellow
developers in diverse production
Landscapes you will be dealing with
taking web apps foundations in Python
Ruby and Meo so Master this project and
you will yield docka file efficiency
like a pro slashing build times and
simplifying setups so say goodbye to
lendy docka file creation and resource
heavy downloads the source code for this
project is also mentioned in the
description box below so don't forget to
check out moving on to project number
three we have Master cicd pipelines
using Azure in this Azure project we
harness Azure devops to create efficient
cicd pipelines this project mainly
focuses on leveraging Azure devops
project we deploy applications seamless
across Azure services like app service
virtual machines and Azure kuber service
or AKs utilizing azure's devop starter
we set up asp.net sample code explore
pre-configured cicd pipelines commit
code changes and initiate cicd workflows
additionally we F tune monitoring with
aure application insight for enhanced
performance insights the source code for
this project is also mentioned in the
description box below moving on to the
next project elevating Jenkins
communication the remoting project the
Jenkins remoting project is all about
enhancing Jenkins communication
capabilities it's an Endeavor to bolster
the Jenkins remoting Library creating a
robust communication layer this project
incorporates a spectrum of features from
TCP protocols to efficient data
streaming and procedure calls as a part
of this project you will start on the
exciting journey of making Jenkins
remoting compatible with bus
Technologies like active mq and rabbit
mq to sued in this project a strong
grasp of networking fundamentals Java
and message cues is your arson dive in
and join us in elevating the way Jenkins
communicates with the world check out
the link mentioned in the description
box below for the source code moving on
to project number five automated web
application deployment with AWS your CD
pipeline project in this project you
will create a seamless continuous
delivery pipeline for a compact web
application your journey begins with a
source code management through a Version
Control System next discover the art of
configuring a CED pipeline enabling
automatic web application deployment
whenever your source code under goes
changes embracing the power of getup AWS
elastic be stock AWS code build and AWS
code pipeline this project is your
gateway to streamline efficient software
delivery the source code for this
project is linked in the description box
below moving on to the next project
containerized web app deployment on gke
scaling with Docker this project will
help you discover the power of
containerization with this project you
will learn how to package a web
application as a Docker container image
and deploy it on a Google kubernetes
engine or gke cluster you can watch your
app scale effortlessly to meet user
demands this Hands-On projects cover
packaging your web app into a Docker
image uploading it to artifact registry
creating a GK cluster managing
autoscaling exposing your app to the
world and seamlessly deploying new
versions you get to unlock the world of
efficient scalable web app deployment on
gke the source code for this project is
linked in the description box below
moving on to project number seven
mastering Version Control with kit in a
world of software development mastering
a version control system is Paramount
version controlling enables you for code
tracking version comparison seamless
switching between versions and
collaborating among developers your
journey in this project will begin with
the fundamental art of code in a VCS
taking the scenic route to set up a
repository you can then start on a quest
through code history and reving the
mysteries of version navigation
navigating through branching a
deceptively intricate task is next on
your path by the end of this project you
will be fully equipped to conquer G one
of the most powerful version control
system tools in the developers Arsenal
the source code for this project is
mentioned in the description box below
moving on to the next project effortless
deploy employment running applications
with kubernetes the major focus of this
project is to help you harness a
straightforward web service that handles
user messages AK to a voicemail system
for leaving messages your mission you
ask you get to deploy this application
seamlessly with kubernetes then
dockerize it by mastering this
fundamental step you will unlock the
power to run your application in Docker
containers simplifying the deployment
process the source code for this project
is mentioned in the description box
below so don't forget to check it out
moving on to the project number nine
mastering terraform project structure
this project will help you maintain and
extend the efficiency of terraform
projects in everyday operations a well
structured approach is essential this
project unveils the art of organizing
terraform projects based on their
purpose and complexity so harness the
power of key terraform features
including variables data sources
provisionals and locals to craft a
streamlined project structure by the end
your project will will effortlessly
deploy an Ubuntu 20.04 server on digital
ocean configure an Apache web server and
seamlessly Point your domain to it level
up your tform game with proper project
structuring and practical application
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below for this s code
moving on to the last project of the day
we have efficient selenium project
development and execution in the world
of test automation selenium projects
play a pivotal role they enable seamless
test execution report analysis and Bug
reporting this proficiency not only
accelerates product delivery but also
elevates client Satisfaction by the end
of this project you will Master the art
of building selenium projects whether
through a Java project or a maven
project showcasing your ability to
deliver high quality results efficiently
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below for the source
code through this project so with that
we have reached the end of the session
on the top 10 devops projects should you
need any assistance PP and other sources
used in this session please let us know
in the comment section below and our
team of experts will be happy to help
you as soon as possible until next time
thank you and keep learning stay tuned
to Simply learn for more amazing updates
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impress impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here